well with me now is the shallow
international development secretary
dynamic she's been at meeting of the
Shadow Cabinet today and after that
meeting Jeremy Corbyn sent out a letter
to MPs saying that he couldn't support
the Prime Minister on extending bombing
to Syria why did you do that though he
wanted to make a decision clear and the
point is that what this is all about is
what will make the British people safe
and Jeremy does not believe that Cameron
has made the case for bombing but the
point is he's the leader leg party and
as I understand it there was going to be
a further meeting the Shadow Cabinet
where the party was going to try and
decide a position yet he's come out with
his position all right I think I think
his concerns were clear in Parliament
this afternoon he felt as leader he
ought to make his position clear and his
position is this bombing will not make
Britain safe any more than bombing Iraq
I think I mean what we hope is that
people will go home over the weekend
that talk to their friends their family
their constituents and then come back on
Monday and we make a final decision I
mean easy not really trying to railroad
these colleagues because we understand
that majority of them some 15 spoke up
against his position in the shadow
cabinet meeting I don't think that was
quite balance the forces and you have to
write would accept the majority spoke
out against what I do accept is Jeremy
appoints the Shadow Cabinet not the
other way around you cannot have a
shadow cabinet voting down the leader of
the Labour Party who's just been elected
with the biggest mandate in history why
can't you have that I mean I he's talked
about new politics collective decisions
on salvation that Jeremy is almost
exactly where party members are on this
70% was YouGov poll this week senator no
party members are against bombing
Germany is where party members are it
would be strange for the Shadow Cabinet
to try and vote down their leader
there's nothing like that in the rule
book clearly Jeremy could we'll consult
and we'll have a discussion but you know
we've all got to be in alignment the
party MPs and the leader of the party
but I mean what we've had tonight is the
shadow foreign the foreign secretary mr.
Benn saying that he thought the Prime
Minister made a compelling are
well I've not heard Hillary statement
but at the end of the day
Jeremy's dude with a party Germans the
one with the mandate we will have a
discussion we will have an agreed
position you have a mandate value item
when you're the elected MP you have a
mandate yes but I didn't contestant is
Janey don't you feel that all the
members of the shadow cabinet actually
represent labor voters who have given
them a mandate just as much as the labor
members who voted for Jeremy Corbyn have
given him one any MP represents that
Constitution when it comes to when it
comes to friend uncle the Labour Party
only Jeremy represents the party as a
whole and you have to respect the fact
that he had the biggest vote of any ever
I don't recall either you or jeremy
corbyn's and respecting previous leaders
you rebelled you took different position
yes but the point here is that Jeremy's
position is the one the members have and
I think members will be even more strong
they don't bomb what members have tended
to select the leader in the past you
haven't respected them in the past no I
think when I voted against the Iraq war
it didn't have the support for them we
found that out yeah but that's not the
only thing you or Jeremy Corbyn have
opposed the previous leaders on he was
we know is rebelled 500 times yes but
you'll find that whenever Jeremy voted
against the whip he was voting in line
with party policy and we have policy on
Iraq and the other thing is that we
debated we debated bombing Syria
constantly characters don't pet that
when he voted against the whip he was
voting in line with party policy well
you take tuition fees who says party
policy is you take tuition fees party
conference never voted on tuition fees
but my point is that when therefore it
wasn't party policy to oppose it I mean
in fact it was introduced that brown
report was commissioned by a Labour
government we can quibble but we're on
the verge of war Jeremy flex where
Labour Party members are we had a debate
at a party conference we've got a
resolution and the view that's all all
all the matters is what the activists in
the labour party you think
not experienced elected MPs now come
back to this elected MPs the Shadow
Cabinet
what matters is what will keep the
British people safe and people must look
at what Cameron has said and make it
tough so what you're saying when you say
that Jeremy Corbyn appoints the Shadow
Cabinet not the Shadow Cabinet appoints
him what you're basically saying is if
they oppose him on Monday there should
be said I'm not saying that I'm just
pointing out I'm just putting up on the
democratic structures Germans the one
that's about the math member so what's
this what's the significance of that
he's going to sack the shadow cabinet if
they don't agree with him no wait the
Devers this procedure is what I said
we'll meet on Monday she's already
separating things and you're saying that
he's got the mandate so what why bother
consult the shadow captain' again which
is what he started people use his
position people might come back after
the weekend having spoken to people and
they might because though there was some
people strongly in favor some people
strong anger against little people in
the middle we don't know what's gonna
happen his position as he did on Trident
what's the point of consulting the party
because in the end
Jeremy believes very strongly in or if
it does come to a vote what is the
parliamentary Labour Party going to do
is it going to be a whipped vote well
it's how you on Monday tell you I'm
having a meeting on Monday then we're
going
I want us to do whatever will keep the
British people safe and you can you
believe that it'll make the bridge with
more expose them to more danger if
Britain joins the Syrian bombing I
believe Cameron's not made the case I
really believe that that's what James
what actually Jeremy Corbyn says I do
not be the primary has made a convincing
case and he says the issue is whether
the Prime Minister's remote one is
proposing strengthens or undermines our
national security
so what Corbin believes and what you
believe is that what the Prime Minister
is proposing undermines national
security all I can say to you is there's
unanswered questions about that I'm
asking that question I'm saying do you
believe
that what the prime minister said today
undermines national security because
that's what Jeremy Corbyn is saying
they've what I am saying it's about the
safety of the British people so you
don't agree with him I always grab my
leader but what I am actually saying is
that it's about keeping the British
people say yeah exactly so you do
believe that going further would
undermine their security you know you've
got to look at it in context with the
context of Jericho yes the situation
there's an absence we think of a proper
diplomatic approach but you know the
party failed yeah that we should put the
diplomacy that I mean you've got the
socialist Defence Minister of France
writing in The Guardian tomorrow
appealing to Britain to support France
in this military effort there's no
question of standing on the sidelines
and doing nothing there's a front
there's a lot to be done to prove that
the Syrian civil war - there's a lot to
be done to allow the regional positive
steps and there's a lot to be done with
with the biggest refugee crisis a
struggle to preserve Jeremy Corbyn as
Labour leader no it's better struggle to
stop us bombing Syria it didn't work in
Iraq it didn't work in Afghanistan and
some of us are doubtful us whether they
were working related Syrian people will
die if we go ahead with his bombers me
you know it's it's we could get drawn
into Al and all 30 people died in Paris
yes they did but we could get drawn into
a land war which would go on and on that
is what we have to consider okay thank
you very much deep down ever